Well, it's me, it sounds stupid,
especially when I'm being filmed when
I say it, but it's [ __ ], I
actually am and it was wonderful
news for me, the most streamed
German artist ever, if you say ever,
strange because it's only been counted since 2015
But in the period I think if
Bushido had had streams back then it would have been
Bushido or Sido or one of
them, but I was lucky to really have a breakthrough
in exactly this phase when streaming was becoming strong,
so I have a bit of an advantage
from that  the length but I'm
actually the most streamed
German artist I'm definitely not going to
start on tiktok now elevator boy
so far I won't do SAS but there
's definitely a way for me too
that rafkaamora
can play tiktok without it becoming embarrassing
That's a hundred percent
solution and since that's the challenge
I have to think about how I do it.
As an artist you only ever have a
certain number of shots, so to speak,
otherwise you will at some point otherwise you will at some
point Lidl we you if you
sell everything  Welcome to the OMR
podcast, once again a podcast from the
rap or hip hop series or
whatever. In any case, I'm a fan of
this type of music and all the
storytelling that has come about in recent years
and it's a
good thing that we're now somehow  Maybe
the central protagonist of the scene of
the last decades in Germany is
here as a guest, yes come on, thank you very much
hi RAF hi I'm now saying RF actually yes
Rafael ragucci no yes exactly and your
language is actually French
and German no exactly yes but
you grew up in  you're essentially in
Vienna in Vienna exactly in the 15th district, that's
a tougher area, so to speak, a harder
area that's a Balkan area, let's say
that, but if you google you,
then immediately the third or
fourth question from Google Suggest is the question what
does Raff have with Slovenia  or
Balkan but do you have roots there too?
No, nothing at all, but I'm
an adopted Bosnian, so to speak, so I
only grew up with Bosnian and you
also speak a little then for
how much I grew up with them,
I speak very poorly but I
understand roughly so  If they now
talk badly about me at the next table,
I understand and your first, so
to speak, me, you
started with music super early, and
the first few years you also
rapped in French. I
rapped in French, but before I
rapped, I did too
played rock and grunch for a very long time and
I actually played a gothic rock band
like how old started with
the music at 11 or 12 and
then you really learned classical instruments
and a piano like that, piano
with violin with four piano with se and
then classical guitar with Zhen I
mean it's yes, I've often spoken to, say,
successful musicians.
At first glance, you still
don't think that they have such a
solid basic musical training
and you don't even think about it in such a
situation  District that then somehow that so the
like a like an idiot
no your parents then wanted
or told so my mother went to Vienna back
then to study opera singing
so and that's why Hal was
directly the lead to the music
and then there's  In Vienna something like
early musical education and so I
was always in music schools until I graduated from
high school, so to speak, I only went to
music schools okay and then at
some point you started with
rap and then at some point you also noticed that German
is easier than French, no, that
was actually the case  A funny story,
I don't even know if I've told it before,
but actually I
should have gone to Marseille
to study there and I changed that with a
call from Jakuza, who was signed at Bushido at the time,
and the one
we have right now  our thing in
Berlin and maybe that would be something
for you and I thought okay immediately
and then I thought okay it's
going to Berlin so I rap in
German like that but before that it was
French okay but
generaluza was say yours so
you  It took a really long time for you to
get your breakthrough, now you're 39 today, yes
and so from 11 to 39, oh, a long
time, but also when, how old were you
when it really
started, way too old, so I think B
and I were both over  30 when PalmOS
plastic came out so it just depends so
I've been able to live off of it since 2009 let
's say I was 25 so that's when it started
that I could pay my mi and
I think in 2014 I
bought my first condominium from
music  That means it started a
little earlier but the real
breakthrough was without my team that
people really heard about in the
clubs was 2016 and is the anecdote true
that you really
lived on the streets for a while and without without a
real one  Apartment yes yes that was just when I was
14 15 I was bugged from home,
as I said youth
was what stress at home you don't know where
you want to go and so on and then okay
but they say
then you still graduated
and so z was too  I think I wrote a book,
I don't know if I
ever told an interview but it was
then I went back to school
so of course you didn't have the year so
you failed
then I went back to school and
said so to the director  I'm putting
my future in your hands, so very
theatrically, I'm putting my
future in your hands either I become
a junky or you take me back
and I'll try again and then
yes and then it was like D that
was equivalence or something like that  Exactly, he
wanted to throw me out again straight after that, so
the next year, but
then somehow I still
managed to get to the Abitur, yes, and
then did you also
somehow start studying
immediately after that, then first
studied musicology for two
semesters and then music management  in
Vienna then in Vienna and then in
Berlin in Berlin and then you were,
so to speak, a smaller rapper in yes
exactly so I was more of a beat producer
so I was more of a beat producer than a rapper then
I was probably like that kick so
there's kick with you  Kick, yes, exactly, I got a
kick out of producing, I was extremely
cheap and that's why everyone
came to me and I
mixed some albums in 48 hours
so that it somehow paid off and I
really worked the night shift
night shift night shift because I
knew okay  The only thing is that the
only Unix selling point is that
I'm cheaper than the others, okay, that's how it
got started, but did you work for someone
that you know? I know
a lot of them anyway, so greetings to everyone that I'm
going to betray now, but then Dibo
Silla at the time, I don't know if you
know Silla from the past, a lot of
people from I love money Records back then
from King Orgasm One and just a
lot of people from the underground
at that time also MP at the very beginning I think
my life is a nightmare
I think it was his first song that was also
recorded by me massively okay massively a
lot of things okay but that's
how it was you could just deal with it
yes and then at some point you
met Bones exactly but that was
well later so it was 2015  We have
n't met, but you say that
the breakthrough has already happened with both of you. You have to say that
you have to say that even for everyone who
might not have an eye on it now,
187 street gangs here from Hamburg have
also become huge in the
last few years  Jesus and so on, you know
the whole crew and you're not
part of this crew, you're
just a friend of the house, so that's
exactly how it is with a gang like that,
either you're a friend of or in
the gang, I was never in the gang  but
I was just like that, let's say for the
last 7 years, I've been so defended that
of course I'm definitely part of it
so now not to the 187 to the
music band 187 but we also do
the management and yes so
l you area then like that
actually know about kontrak so I
had made a song with kontraak who
then said hey greetings from B
unknown and I said okay
greetings unknown back
actually there is a funny story
Bones used to listen to my music so at the
very beginning my first tapes
and has  I
took a photo with me at a flea market in Berlin, so to
speak, as a fan, and he told me
straight away that I think it
's really good, he's not ashamed
to tell Hal something like that, and then he
called me and then it actually started
without without foreplay nothing at all so
straight in we flew straight to
Jamaica, shot our first
single there and then we were already
married so straight straight straight
straight you just want to understand each other so well on a
musical level or
so it would have gone wrong  can go,
so we've said it quite often anyway,
so it could have been the case
that we don't like each other at all
and then B and I are both
people that if we don't
get along with someone then we don't want to get along with that
person either  We work like that, so we
got on very well with each other,
okay even if we're different and that's just a
thing, but back then it was already
clear if you wanted to do something
then you had to immediately Jamaica, that's
the big cutlery, yes, that was
our vision  We both had the
same vision, that's of course
the thing that connects us, so we
both thought we were big fans
of danol, but up until now there wasn't a
German alternative from danw that we
thought was cool, so there wasn't a
bit of street  a bit really,
the dan that existed in Germany at the time
was a gentleman or very
few defflame and so on, there was
relatively no, you don't have to say, so
there was Peter Fox and so on, that was
n't really dan like that and
then I got it  I'm okay, then the
best place to do it is in Jamaica, where else not
in China and then it worked straight away. Did you
or did you both
already have a social media
reach and something like that so B much more
than me so I have to say too  and that's what
I said B for the first few years
I said if you hadn't come
who knows what would happen to me W so who
knows what happened W so Bones
was the social media boss who
played with social media like a
trumpet  It was really but
there's also somehow a certain thing about it.
I've known him for a
while and as you see, I think
he just has an incredibly good
visual view of things, you
think that somehow his images are
there too  So much in there, he knows
how it was censored, yes, full, so B
is a a 360° artist, so he and
that was just what was right, they
both knew because I was
already there in terms of management, so
all the things that I did
I did it myself and because of that
we both had a bit of that management
eye and we knew
straight away without talking to each other that okay
that's embarrassing that's not
embarrassing okay you can do that
you can't do that but B was much more
intuitive  when I was and that was just the
blatant thing and he was just
never ashamed that was I was always
ashamed that was extremely ashamed
well in general so for example when we
were in Jamaica I was ashamed
just in a
complete stranger dance so in
Going into some completely strange club where there
are only locals and dancing in the middle of the
dance floor to their music, that's what it
was for me, I thought to myself, I do
n't know if they're up for it, I didn't give a
[ __ ], I
just went in there and he was
right  so it was always always cool
so you
definitely created my cool pictures and of course
the sound when or after how much time
did the palm plastic come into being
right away that was that
after that that was one of the
first songs, so to speak  PAL so our first song
was we're writing history even though we
hadn't written anything at
that point so no history at all
and then BS said it
smells like a collab album and I
said okay then let's go and then
it started right after that and then  then
I mean that's one of the
songs that was created that is
probably the most successful rap song of the
last few decades in Germany
without my team, yes, definitely that,
but that was immediately the one
that he was then number two
or dre on the Z on the it was on
the album but that was just Bones
never wanted to release the song so that
yes so I've told it many times but
maybe now I'll tell people
who don't even know the story exactly
so I have it  I wrote the song
lying in
my bed with half a herniated disc on my side. I produced the beat
on my
laptop, then went up to my
kitchen, left the beat playing,
cooked spaghetti old Tonno and
wrote the lyrics on the side, so I do
n't really care about it  I thought about
what I was writing because it
should have been a feature with
MHD, the actual
inventors of this type of music, and that's
why we wanted
to do a song like that Afro trap because it was the
only Afro trap song on the album  and
then I went into the studio and
quickly recorded my part and then
it lay there for the first time because we
waited for the answers until something
came, but there was never an answer and
then at the end we were almost ready to hand it in
and thought to ourselves, okay, we
only have 14 songs and 15 have to be I
think that's how it was
and then I said to BR e the
song is still there and D me the song
sucks I said yes but it's not that [ __ ]
so I find a lot of people
like that  We heard it and did
n't think it was that bad, I don't know, and then
Maxw happened to be there, so there was also one of
Maxw von7, then we went into the
kitchen. Max Part was written. Max
Part
was recorded  the S is
no better then I said yes, well
then Maxw and I alone will bring
out the song, so to speak, and then he said
no, that's even more ridiculous if
you have a song together on our collab album
and then BS sat
up when he sat down and
thought about it  yes okay good to Sete
Mercedes and then I thought okay
now you're making the song ridiculous
because what has to do with it then he
recorded it and all three were
dissatisfied with the song and that's the
story of team and and then
you have  Just put it on it
because we were there in Bosnia
and shot a video about the murderer
and Maxw was also with us and on the way. The
route between Bosnia and Vienna was
Croatia and then we were
in Croatia for a short time and said okay, good  Look is
there when our cameraman max is there I'm there
he then just let's
shoot quickly without my team if we're already there
video that this famous video
famous video was freestyle like that and
then we went to Vienna
we thought okay we need  After
a party scene a friend of mine
said a roof terrace okay let's go up
to the roof terrace we have to
do a poolpy we didn't have a pool
then we somehow got an inflatable pool
of course without an
air pump that
meant we had to inflate it ourselves that means we had
half a pool  inflated pool on a roof
where we didn't have a sound system so we
only had the music on our cell phones so
we didn't even have a box where the
music was playing and we did
n't have a hose to fill the pool,
which means we took a parasol
then somehow to a
water pipe so to speak let
the water run in through the parasol,
which means W a half-filled
pool in a half-inflated pool
and there was the legendary pool scene from
Maxwell for the people who know the video
is now offline yes that's how it is
B taken offline why because
here with this on bes bes doesn't like this bes
isn't a fan of leaving old things
online where he thinks okay
he no longer sees himself visually like that or he
no longer sees some things visually
the way they fit now but that
Thing doesn't know over 100 million
the BS warmest no matter yes awesome I
mean that was probably the
most successful music video or I have
so I have probably yes probably
yes but that's just how it works
so I understand with us in this case
and that also helped me  To
defend him, I also said from the beginning that
just like I
delete pictures on Instagram or put them
offline, I also do the same with videos, so
be aware that we are
making the video but then I might
put them offline again and then I have
a lot  I delayed the moment for a very long time
and he said that at the latest with PalmOS
Plasti 3 I'll put it offline again,
okay, everything's clear, but in my opinion that's because
I still have all these motorcycle images in my head,
so no, that's 500 HP ah,
okay, okay, I'll hit the gas  the 500 hp was
also a really big one okay okay Palm 2
was that ah okay okay then I'll come but
anyway I ah no you mean that with
the motor then you mean palmus plastic
the video that's already uplin that's
where we were with them  Palms Beuch
are in Hamburg the two motorcycles
the B people on the high on the sit
something like that yes exactly so me and dening yes
exactly D with with with also team and so
or me so I I have the things
so yes I think you are just mixing
all videos together in one video but that
's roughly how it was because I
looked at things a lot to stop
or or just let them run, that's
how you consume Hal music,
you just turn on YouTube and then
you look at it and listen  But exactly
but in principle all the videos
were exactly the same so it was always
the same values ​​always motorcyclists always
crocodiles always women and always boys
who scream so that was our
concept must is that so those are the
people you need it was definitely
100% expensive  Guys, everything and
after that we were just so okay Phew, we
've already shot five times, what do
we do now, let's go to Tokyo and
do the same thing in Tokyo so so so that
thing was then and then that with Leile over
so it's no longer sucked through
It's just like that, but
what do you have to do today? Good
question, very good question
Well, you don't know, you can never
say, so it's actually like shooting
somewhere by chance,
maybe you wo
n't hit it, so I can
sort of estimate which direction it
might go, but you don't know, do
you think that it was mine with you
too?  So come to think of it, you've
always said over the years that I'm going to
stop now, actually
my music career is over and then
you wrote a book and then
thought about it and then the pandemic and then
started again, exactly I'm quitting again now
So I'm I'm
also right now like but I'm
just asking whether you know the
history as a musician whether you do that so that
means you don't have the dream of
mountain I'm that do that at 75 80 I'm
pulling for a whole life  that through
so it depends on what I don't
want and what I never wanted is I say
so I don't want to go as what
I used to be s I want to go as what
I am like that and the thing is
when I  I'm now 75 years old and
I'm performing on stage with my cap backwards without my team and I'm
leaving as what I used to be and
that definitely bothers me.
I want to develop further and that's why
that's part of it. So I was actually 19
so I thought okay, now it's over,
now I'm really going to stop, so that was when
I was aware that I was
stopping before, so in 2010 I stopped and
then made Alter Ego RAF 3 and
then started with this
reggy and that one  The whole thing and I just did
n't want to disturb RAF kamora because of it.
I thought to myself, there's
nothing worse for me than if
Metallica makes
a Pop I don't know skatebank album tomorrow,
then I ca
n't take Metallica seriously anymore and that's it
for me  When I was 30, I
thought to myself that if I suddenly wanted to play a
completely different kind of music, I would also want a
different name because otherwise
I'd be a bother
and then in 2019 I
stopped when the
pressure to succeed was simply too high for me, yes where does
kamora come from at RF kamora that was
also a funny story so when I
came to Germany my
name was RFF simply me from rfael I
never thought about it
Artist name and then there was already an
RAF in Frankfurt who was signed at Aard
here also rfael and I thought to myself out of
respect I'm coming to your country,
so to speak, to Germany and ca
n't just get the name from some rapper who
's been there longer than me
I thought okay, what do
I call myself Grind FLX
none of that and then my DJ Hug said
yes, you're Italian, you
're from southern Italy, I just call it R
kamora and I thought it sounds
good, sounds good then
I just  instead of z r I took an R so
kamora that sounds a bit like an
artist's name that's not
directly based on the camor but it
sounds something like that yes and so but
sounds good so when I'm abroad they
say artist
nelich
designer well say this one  The whole look
and also the texts are
let's say this now often this
gangster look and
a lot of it is you or was it a
bit like the spirit of the times so the thing
is if you don't ask you are you are you
that you have  Yes, a psychologist, I do
n't know exactly what he said, so how
exactly he said it, but he
said something like this: your
current self
probably has much, much less to do with your ten-year-old self
than
the ten-year-old sitting next to you back then knows what
I mean that means you're
constantly changing, yes, but of course
we come from that, so of
course I'm from the environment, I
grew up in the 15th district,
I've been on the street so to speak
under quotation marks all my life, so now I'm not
homeless, but I  My whole life
was my environment
one hundred percent
and of course you sing or rap about what you
see and we were
never in any bonszenraurants or anything like that from the age of 14 to 30,
so I was
n't even in the first one in Vienna  District so we
were we represented what
we are the street is 100%
but if you ask me now if I
still do that if I sell grass in 15 Bezi
no I don't so that's
why my last album is now
called XW what  In French so vi
means something like Ex City which
basically means Ex Streets vou so young so and I I
can of course
talk about it because just when a man
goes blind doesn't mean that he
has never seen anything so to speak so I know
all that but am  Of course it's not
anymore now I'm already in in open
restaurants now I'm
no longer selling weed on the block now I have a
different life so but but it also means
that you change your your your your your your
music accordingly so that's
actually the current version of the  you're
talking today but that's just how it goes as I said
about the blindness. We
made a song on PalmOS with the
same name and that was because we
were in Jamaica and
asked our local friend from there, so to speak,
why is Webes Kartel singing?  still so
webes kartel s a very so the
danzol artist actually why does he
still sing about Parys blah blah blah when he
's been in jail for years and
then he said in Jamaican I
unfortunately can't imitate what he
said but he  In terms of content,
he
said that just because a man is blind does
n't mean that he's never, of course some
are blind from birth, but
it doesn't actually mean that he's never
seen anything, that means when
he talks about partying, he's already had a
party  That means he has the
right to talk about it and for
me it's just natural if I make
a street song that's about
something, then I have the
right to talk about it, whether I'm
still in the mood
to rap about it at all  another thing,
well that was honestly one
thing that I'm less interested in
talking about more now, so it's
simply because I don't feel that way anymore, which is
also a reason why you're saying it again now,
actually I'm just stopping right now,
but it could be  that maybe
in a year or two
something new will somehow touch you again and
then you say okay then
one hundred percent something
new will come that touches me and where where
I then know where I'm going and there are already
a lot of currents
in there  me where I think okay,
I could do that, I could do that, I
could do that, but I wait and
focus a bit now in which
direction it goes for myself
so that I then know okay, I'll do that
because I don't feel like that right now
to make five songs that go in that direction
five songs in which the
wasted wasted creativity
somewhere there are other
artists perhaps from a different
generation or who
have particularly inspired you Buba in France
inspired me a lot, which for me is, if
I would say, an
all-time role model  is Buba from France
and he is actually one of
the few rappers where I think it's
amazing, he always did something new,
his style
was always hated for it at the
beginning but then he was
significantly involved in it  The
direction French rap
has developed is like this and that was the thing
for me, otherwise no irendwi if you
look at the distance, I'm
not that into the French SZ now then
you think
American zero or J or something like that never in
my life I could never
never listen to a song by J, not not 5
seconds, I don't listen to his voice,
so respect respect really to the K
business performance, everything is top notch but the
music for me in my ears I ca
n't listen to it otherwise there is
no other sietag future is mine
favorite army rapper is
future that's it and I thought it was
brocky mixtap back then I don't know if
live love one of them back then where there
was something on WhatsApp what so
I think it was the first song with a white
video anyway and so back then I did
really celebrated at some point it became too clear to me,
don't know, strange, okay,
but nothing else in America, just
say a little bit for people who ca
n't really hear you yet,
a few numbers about
your musical peak, like how many
records or  yes records s
you still have then or
units means I think you've
sold how many streams are there
sousam just do a few so I'm
it sounds stupid especially if I'm
filmed when I
say it but  It's [ __ ] I
actually am and it was wonderful news
for me the most streamed German
artist ever if you ever say it's funny
because it's only been counted since 2015 but
in that period I think if
Bushido had had streams back then it would have been
Bushido or Sido or  one of
them but I was lucky enough to really have a breakthrough right in
this phase where streaming was becoming strong
and that's
why I have a bit of an advantage
in terms of the length but I'm
actually the most streamed
German artist myself somehow
this year too  still like that or I
mean I've now looked somehow at
least significantly bigger than or something like that
so now not if you
really think it's huge worldwide
mainstream but in the end you do more
streams I think last year than
in Germany exactly in
Germany  yes, yes, full and you
have to do something, say technical,
it's also a bit so that
you somehow use this platform
particularly cleverly. I once
heard that some people consciously make
very short songs or very long songs or
1000 tricks but or is it really possible
just about making good music,
I think the thing is, a lot of fans
from the past sometimes accuse me of that
and say yes, you're now making short
music, short songs because Spotify.
Actually, it's not about
Spotify at all for me, I just make short songs
because I  I just think
it's been divided into three parts, you know what
I mean, so three, you don't need a
third part, it's annoying to me, so when I
hear a song I don't want to hear a third part, I'd rather
hear the song again, but of course there are
a few tricks  under
quotation marks,
I don't know whether they're true or not, but
of course there are things like don't do a
one-minute intro so people will
keep on singing, so try
to get to the point quickly, but that was the case back
then when you had a hit
or  a song that should be successful
then you should actually have to right
at the beginning I mean
zwevana SM spe the same way and you know
okay you're in you know so so
so much hasn't changed at all in terms of
strategy okay so every
platform needs its  own logic and
everyone can do it, so in
my opinion, hits were
already hits back then, so if you
listen to a hit in the 80s, you will know that
you press play and the hit knows
what I mean and today too and
becomes accordingly
Of course, these songs are streamed more, I guess,
and accordingly, if you
actually make a song that you think,
okay, that will be the single and
I'm basing it on the single, then you produce it
a little bit in that direction and
what role does
other people play these days?  Platform when
Spotify was with you, I think,
we just spoke a bit of YouTube,
so the videos we also
had really really views, not
so tiktok anymore, so YouTube is, I say,
greetings from undo kado unfortunately unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately the videos are just
the  People no longer have the
attention span
to give a whole video, so unfortunately what
you used to put into videos
would now actually be uneconomical to
spend so much on it and then
you'd rather do some tiktok
stuff now, so of course we still have it now
for all of our PalmOS
Plastic 3 or I for my album still
really invested in the
videos economically it did
n't make any sense at all so it would have been 1us times
better if we had invested that
in a blatant Tiktok campaign or something like that,
okay that's called campaign  then
I also buy advertising, not only
buying advertising but also
campaigns in our thing is
of course you can also do it for €0
if you're creative,
for example my last single that I
made with chiago is just social
media  Boss 2023 for me so in something like that
and he just knows how it works
and he just said while we were
filming the video, hey wait, let's
do another tiktok now.
I wouldn't have even thought of the idea
then he did  We have to do this and that,
these are all things that I don't
know, um, and when I say it's better to
invest in a Tiktok campaign, it's
more likely that because we
're not native Tiktokers, it's more likely that we'll get a few
people involved and just see that
we have Tiktok  great played so
I would say that makes more sense now than
€70,000 for a music video does
n't bring anything at all but that's how
the price points used to be when you
have to make a good video that's 70 we're
still like 50 60 70 and I mean that's
Yes, it's still cheap when I hear that now,
flying to Jamaica or
flying somewhere with a team
and all that stuff, that's
actually achieved quickly, then yes, we
didn't have a problem who did everything alone,
so Tokyo was just
him without a light man  without anything but
in itself yes in itself achieved quickly so
if you don't have CIA casado now okay
and W if now you also have a
bit of a reason to stop again is
also because that's what the platform says, I'm
no longer a native so I mean is
Yes, it's still pretty hard to experience that
suddenly commitments, what you
know no longer counts so much and that
now there's a whole new platform
that you don't even know, but
that's more things that
I enjoy  So I know, for example, in 2015
when trap
came and the 16-year-olds at the time
grew up with trap, so to speak, and I
had completely different habits
of making songs, I thought to myself,
okay, now I'll practice, so now
I'll sit down and write 30 songs
They don't have to come out but I - I
just practice so that I can
get great at this thing and that's more of a
challenge for me and things that I
like so there's no
way I'm going to start on tiktok now
elevator boy moderately
soow SAS I will  Don't do it, but
there's definitely a way for me too
that rafcamora
can play tiktok without it becoming embarrassing,
so that's a hundred percent
solution and since that's just the challenge,
I have to think about how I can do it,
but I mean, that's
bitter  Because you used to be able to
build a music career for 30 years, there
was some kind of logic more or
less and now you have to constantly
get new ones every few years, so
okay, but that's just the way it is, so that's just the way
the game is, so I think it's
difficult  to say it used to be
better, it's just not
earlier anymore, in my opinion, of course for metallicaa,
what's cool is an album every four years,
but making music these days
also ends up making social media a little bit
say the music
has to be good but
only find good music Hal just doesn't have any
yes so it just has to be when I
say 360° art is just you have to have the
image, which of course used to
be important too but in the past you could
just fix your image  your logo
and then a record cover so whether you
walk around privately when your logo is black privately purple no one
noticed because there was no nothing at all
his paparati but nowadays I
notice everything you do and that's
why you also have to sharpen your image
moderately simply when you  know okay, that's
the world you want to see, I'm
not talking about the fact that you should get an
artificial image,
you can just do that, it's just part of the game,
but if you know okay this and that, your
image, that's what you put there with your music
and that  If you're supposed
to represent yourself as an artist, it's also important that you
move in this cosmos,
so if, for example, Rafael Ragucci likes to
read books
about Mada, I know M is my big
hobby and I breed M doesn't fit,
I don't need to tell people  That's
just none of my business in my opinion so okay
but that means you're already
pretty congruent with your image
privately these days so
I say I always say that RF kamor is
a part of Rafael Ragucci and not the
other way around okay so it is
Of course there are parts of me as a person that
have nothing to do with rafcam,
but everything that is rafcamor has
to do with me, which in my opinion I know absolutely and I
mean what you also have a
lot of now, it's just your economic
side  The art already had a
kitalist dirty side, you were
on the cover of the forbs twice si times
white suit no such a white T-shirt
from now I can say from Y3 which
I blurted out because I'm with Puma
out of respect for Puma okay  Okay, but
in any case, there are a
whole series of businesses, the first one
we've already heard was
just making beats, so to speak, and then what was that
after that, where you said okay,
now I'll start, so to speak, to talk
about money  To think about it
was D when you started as a producer,
no, music management, so it was
right where I started, so
actually the first business move that
I made in music management
terms was our P at the time, which was called Scandal IP
and we were able to use it  not
finance it and then I
thought it would actually be smart
if we had a zip file like that because back then there
was no streaming, nothing at all, it
was just that was the big time of
illegal downloads, so I thought
okay, well if you don't have any money anyway  If you start
selling CDs then I'll make
a zip file and just go to
friends and say hey give me
a little money sponsor 1000 € 500 €
blablabla and I'll put your logos in
this zip file that means people will
download the album and
still have it  such a PDF
and there are simply logos in it like that and that's what
we did back then and
just asked friends like that and yes and
then it became a biness that was
just in the beginning that's how we
financed our first things that's how I was able to
After that, with this money, I
sat people down, including my sister, and said hey, look, I
mean, my sister didn't
take any money, but otherwise I'll give you
a little money for it, they're all spamming in front of you and it's just
the thing
I have this sponsorship money, which isn't
€2000, I have no idea and you're
just spamming everything and so that was the
thing and then the next business thing
I had was with my first
mixtape, I thought okay, how do
I promote it and then Dibo gave me that  My
label boss at the time bought an Interrail
card and gave me an Interrail
ticket and I
somehow sneaked into
a sticker printer guy who said
hey, I still have one of those tapes or I have no
idea how it worked and I can tell you
Make stickers cheaply, just give a
quick motif and then I
took two suitcases full of stickers, took the
Interrail to every city,
did some stickers
for myself for my mixtape and
then the sales department actually did it too
because I knew it was coming
those with something like that and they see
that there's a bit of promo behind it
and then they make an effort and they
actually noticed it,
awesome, they did a sticker campaign
and so on, they didn't know it
was me alone, so that's
Interrail-like  so so so
you have to imagine Bahnkart 100 like that and then
drove there and then you had to
think about where is the
best place to stick it exactly and that's where I did it,
that was also funny, it was maisbace time
and a friend of mine
has the few  People who heard my music
wrote to me and
said I'm the manager of
rafcamora and I'm completely disabled
when you hear it now but said
RF kamora can maybe sleep with you
because he's currently doing his
promo tour and stuff like that back then and then
I actually slept with a fan in every city,
so
any fans are now all e.g.
Ribellu from Cologne, who I'm still friends with, so
I slept with them
in Hamburg, so I
slept with a girl in Hamburg, who is
Elisa  and back then we
embroidered together, so she, her friend and
I and where where do you embroider then where does
it make sense to do so where if you are now S
in Hamburg or yes, the
fans where I sleep knew that, they knew that
there is the sticker
hotspot and  We were in Hamburg, I do
n't remember what this street was like, but it was
crazy and that means you
ultimately felt an effect
through the stickers because then
other people said okay,
great, they're doing the right campaign, ask
for music, then we can  also
invest Kön that's exactly the thing so it
's actually always and it's like that
in business I mean every businessman
who's listening now will know it's a
bit of a shoot up and because
you've shot it up there you shoot
it up there and so on  and so on, so it
feels like nowadays it's
sometimes faster than me. You
really
had to work hard for a long time to get there,
but now I don't know, Apache, it
was a lot quicker, yes, but I'll
say that it's the same today  There are still
arts that just take longer,
but today
you can burn yourself out quicker, which
means that if you spam Tiktok as an artist today
and it doesn't work,
you've already burned your name somehow. Back
then we had a bit of
an advantage that no one noticed
That doesn't work, you know, that means I
was able to play the same Club 200 location on tour for 10 years
and
people didn't really check
that I was now unsuccessful all the
time because it just wasn't
seen that way, you know, people
have  Yes, not that
interested in that if you do
something on tiktok today for 10 years
you'll be an old ham at some point,
even after six months you'll be an
old ham, you still have
the CH okay now but now you can see
at Trettmann Trettmann was
unbelievable  how long he made music
until it became successful so yes yes
but with you in the end it was the
collaboration with B so and and but then in
terms of reach build social media
to reconstruct it like that yes so
it was just the thing it it  was a
merger that just fit, so there are
sometimes mergers that don't fit at all, for
example if you mix Red Bull with Red Bull
then you just have Red
Bull again, that won't work any better,
but if you mix Red Bull with wortk then
you just have one  Drink that
makes people drunk and happy so then it
's a good mix and with bonses
it was exactly the same so bonses was super
edgy super
but the perception came from social media on
I mean about its reach exactly
not just about the reach it was just fine
too  it was just about the
chemistry I was always a very very
respected musician so it was in the
musician circles in the scene I was
respected the people the people knew
okay I have diepe theme I do
n't do [ __ ] so to speak and 187 were
just wild and  loudly yes and they were also
super badass musicians as BS,
but that wasn't known at the time and through
the collaboration with me,
Bones became a bit more legit in this serious
matter and I became
a bit more legit in the other
sphere and that's why  It was just an
incredibly good match, okay, but
what does it mean if you're an
artist today? I mean, you're a
producer now, you're also looking for
new artists yourself, then you look
at the
range, you just look at the
music, what do you think  Guys, it
's a bit difficult these days
because as soon as you want to se someone, they're
already gone. I had the
Apache thing, I think I've
already told the story, so I should have
been Apache like that and didn't
do it or it was too late  It was simply because you
've already seen it and
that's unusual, it's good and
then no, it was actually the
thing, it was a very, very good friend of
mine. Eldor took her with him
to the airport where they picked me up,
he and  apachche and then they
drove me to a festival
and it's also a funny thing apach
had a
fake fake Rolex
daydate Rosé with a green dial and
I said so real and he said no
no but soon I got a good good attitude and
then I  Then somehow songs
were played and so blah from my new
album back then and I said to
Hardi who was sitting in the back I said so
I'm still missing a feature and Apache
has driven says yes, how about AP
207 I think who is that in my opinion  yes,
I'm looking at it so hard, yes, believe me,
listen to the stuff, then he
played the stuff for me. I think it was
desta Rossa, yes, and I thought the
stuff was awesome, so I thought it was really
intense, so awesome voice, awesome, everything
back then  The lyrics were a
bit too much for me. If I had known that there would be
a song like this with Udo Lindenberg
then I would have thought okay, good is
exactly what you need but at the time
I thought okay the lyrics weren't
edgy enough for me but I thought it was great  good
and B also thought it was really awesome
but we were just too slow back
then. We had Palmus Plastik 2 back then. That was
really in the middle of our hottest
phase. We had so much to do that I
just thought based on my story,
I know how to be an
artist  If a management
is someone and isn't 100%
committed, it's the worst thing that
can happen to you as an artist and that's why
I thought to myself at the time, I'd just wait a bit, I'd
still need time and in the
meantime of course he Lukas
Teuchner W did it  Lukas
Teuchner and Buser yes yes yes okay, tell
me your father back then,
you played a lot live, I
think you also played the largest
German-speaking or German-speaking
raumstatt for a live concert,
I read about Hel
Fischer in Munich, I think  I played in front of 130,000
people and you somehow 120,000
120 but there were maybe 130 so
that was like the dark number is
higher and then you just
had the idea yourself that you could do it
or you can, no, the Danube Island Festival has been going on
since  I have no idea how many years ago, so
I'm going to say some number
700, well Falco back in the
90s, I think
it was in the 90s, that's what the legendary Danube
Island Festival was in Falco then, then there was
Danzer with ambos blabbla and
it was just that  for me always wow
danube island festival I have to play sometime
I also played in 2003 or
I don't know when and we just
played that in front of no one so we
no one so in front of no audience it was
just somehow my sister's sister
of my buddy's with
rapped to me so that was it, there was no one
there and that was just a bit I
thought to myself okay [ __ ] at some point I have to get
it done because we were
at the Donauinselfest every year and this
year we did it and then
it was so big  because then people
wanted to see you, yes, but you didn't get anything out
of it, you only got a fee, I
think I got a fee,
I guess you just wanted to do it
because there was just so there are
actually things that are
our big image  because we're
very happy that we're BU podcast,
so our
um
light ne le light sentences in the business are,
for example, in front of coal and so it doesn't
matter how much money it brings, if
it destroys your image, you wo
n't get all the money  Because then
you no longer have your main thing
and you simply can't do business anymore
and sometimes it's the other way
around. There are things that are so
great for the image that the money doesn't matter
and you're talking to me about it now,
I know that  It's
worth a lot more to me than it is now,
but somehow you also got a fee, but of
course I got a fee,
but on the tour with
the tour you will also, I mean, that
was also a huge, let's say
locations that there  played or so
several times now actually until
Corona and then after Corona
again yes yes I
played tour twice last year where the
Arena Mercedes-Benz is the biggest thing and
there is something like that D not now in the future do
you mean if you  there isn't anymore
so I mean that's the way it is, I was
just watching Rob Williams on
Netflix then you think okay how
can you get back down there if you
do, it depends on what kind of guy you
are so Kurt killed himself because
hated it so much and I'm a
little bit between Roby Reen and Kurt
so I'm honest,
so for me the live performance is
n't so much about
feeding my narcissistic
crocodile but rather
a little more about the
art of it  like live
theater or I don't know what to
call it but I'm also incredibly
nervous and that's why for me
this tour makes me just as nervous
as I'm looking forward to it, so
if all that were to go away then there would be
less cortisol
and less dopamine so it would
come to zero okay that means you so you
can just want to you could
say step back live I could live live
will be the easiest thing for me to really
step back and live would also be the
thing where I would say from a
certain age I would have  I don't feel like
being on stage anymore, at least
unless my music is so advanced that I
can agree, but I mean, look
at the Rolling Stones,
but I don't think they play with it, to be
honest, I don't think it's cool,
I don't want to see it  I do
n't want Kurt Kobin either if he understood now from the
grave I would want to
go because I'm the biggest niwan fan
ever but not ever maybe
you're a bigger fan but I'm a
very big nan fan but I would
n't be in the mood kurtin  to be seen on
stage at 60 because he is a young wild
artist kurtin I don't want to
see the other Ken that's the thing so
I want to see what he was but
it's no longer that's why in
my opinion he has nothing for me  more
lost okay okay what's it like from an
economic point of view so live is
now also lucrative the game no
I would have thought somehow D that at
the so if you can play in venues as big
as you the opposite so that
's de the the these  The curve, so to speak,
doesn't move the bigger the more
you earn, but the production
then becomes super expensive, um you need
seven trucks, you need your own
stage, you take with you and so on, so
I'll say some things in the live
area that are much smaller are a
lot  More lucrative, okay, I'm not a booker,
I'm not a booker now, nor am
I an organizer because I can't be where
the perfect
thing is now, but I guess 3 to
5,000 locations are perhaps
more lucrative than if you do 20,000,
because that's the real promo for you
and yes for yourself,
self-improvement, so I'm going to go
on my tour that's coming up in
March. I don't think I
'll earn that much from it, so
of course I'll earn a little bit,
but I don't think I'll
even earn what I earn from it
Earn an appearance at a festival here SH David has
already told me that it's
a pure
advertising investment for her on the one hand,
you just look at Taylor Swift and
the okay one billion sales with
toursz, yes, but that can't
burn away  or one so I like I said, I
know now with Taylor Swift I
don't know but it's so big and so that's
why I guess with Taylor
Swift it's about the same as with
others just in a
gigantic thing that's why I think
their expenses too  Hal is
just as gigantic, I don't know what
she deserves from it and in the end,
maybe for Taylor Swift, no idea, 20
million
euros isn't that great,
maybe a lucrative
once-in-a-day festival is quite
okay for you, but what does it mean in the end, so
to speak  If you look at the musikb it's
streaming streaming there's
streaming
coops streaming cooperations site
businesse something like when Shirin
David or KI make their TS that's a
lot of money like that if it
works otherwise of course live so
if you have no idea a club show like that  You
're a type of guy and you
have a lot of money like that, that wouldn't
suit you now, no, it wouldn't
suit you and you've already
tried to say that you have a lot of
business, but that's because we were just
talking about tea or or alcohol  and
so you've already tried things
where you say somehow I'd
rather not have done them, so I'll say
that out of the ten things you do,
you'll probably miss up to eight times,
so there are definitely
things that I've done  I think
okay, it was stupid, so there weren't any
things that I really did negative with,
but just things that I
thought to myself,
as an artist you
always only have one, a certain number
of shots, so to speak, yes, you otherwise, at
some point you'll be an otherwise  At
some point you will Lidl you know if you
sell everything I know that's hot
concentrate on a maximum, I'll say
really by hook or by crook like
five things like that
and if you fill them up with I
sell cookies I sell and I know
where I'm talking  I did all that
was lemonade that you made White
Crocodile that was with Bones then
the story was that you did
n't really like it
because you never actually drink sweet drinks
and then you had to push and
have yourself with it  felt uncomfortable h always
noticed yes well that's just the thing there
are some things that I do
without being ashamed of it as a business
because I just think to myself okay that's
just business that's
marketing now I don't have to be
100% behind every product
so I do  I don't have to
do it 100% myself, so
to speak, but of course I have to stand by it,
so if it was like
lemonade that makes you blind then
I wouldn't sell it, but
I also eat sugar from time to time but
it was now we have it more  made it
because we thought okay, that's
the thing right now, a lot of
people are making a lot of money so
a company came to us and said hey
if we start this now for your
album PalmOS Plastick 3 blah blah blah then
it'll be awesome and so on
We thought we'd make a lot of money from it, sure,
okay, then we'll do it, why not?
You know why not, but it didn't
work out. What was the best thing you
've done so far in my business from the
business side? I have to say R, then
my tattoo and barbershop in Vienna because
that's the only business where I say
that really runs on its own, it has
almost nothing to do with me anymore, so
it runs on its own, that's we've already got
the investment back in, we
already have a second branch
opened in in Salzburg we it
always goes a long way but I also
read major teething problems ne R
no not so much but I
read somewhere h you first the
manager again ah that yes yes okay that yes yes
yes that definitely so  so that
before it started so if that
means yes yes so that was I thought to myself
during my break I thought to myself okay I
have to do something because otherwise
I'll go crazy because I had no
more music I had no
more performances I thought to myself if I didn't  I
'll do something then I'll kill myself
and then you have a barbershop and a tattoo
shop but it's at the end, say if you
now have two three of them, it's
still a small business comparison,
so the tattoo business is actually
big and that's what you do
you can expand it e.g. you can
then because you have a barbershop you
can legitimately also
make barber products you know you
can then make creams you can
make hair wax you can just
do things like that and then it's not out of
the random h  why is this
rapper now selling hair cream in my opinion that means
you have other things
opening up and the tattoo business is
actually not a small business and
especially not if you
do it in the way we do it
so we don't have just any
messed up tattoo now  Shop but it
's really nice so there's a
big investment behind it and that's
but I still mean how much TTO how
many tattoo artists work because we have
12 tattoo artists even more so tise
up to 16 tattoos and then they
somehow do it on the day  not everyone does
three tattoos or SAS yes yes but they
do every few thousand euros a day okay
okay and D that's a
bigger studio in Vienna yes I think 350 square
or so or bigger and now we've
opened the second one in Salzburg  and
we even wanted to do something in Dubai
and so on, but that's just
not possible, but otherwise it's just a
business where I say okay, it
works without me, I also have to
say I have a very, very capable
managing director and partner, that's
about it  That's what I learned, that's what I've
learned. When I open something new, there has to
be a team
behind it, there has to be someone behind it who is 100%
invested in it because otherwise I
'm a musician, I still invest
100% in rafkaamora and all the
other things first  There has to be someone behind it
who is just as invested in the thing
with passion
as I am in rafcamora and
I found it in Vienna and that's
why it runs on its own and there are
also at the end the school is
known because you promoted it
because  it's yours because everyone knows
that's your thing and so on right at the
beginning, what do I want to have promoted and
stuff like that in the media and
blah blah blah but after that there are
a lot of things that come from rappers
that are wow at the beginning  Everyone goes there
and after a week nobody goes
there anymore and then the reason why it
works well for us is because, firstly, as
I said, we have a very good
management team and one
of them is very, very strong with
advertising like that and blah blah blah and
actually comes  a lot of it
through this ADS switching through this
advertising and so on I
recently someone told me how big
the piercing business could be,
what was happening then let's start
singing from now on for all of you now
50% reduction whoever that is  I've heard
so I really had the
individual studies in the G but
of course you can think of it bigger, right, yes,
I have no idea what it
looks like exactly, I would have
had to google it but it's very nice, it's really
very nice, it's very  nice for me
so we had and we also had
ambition so my inspiration was
a tattoo studio in Barcelona run by Elijah
hot, a model from England, I thought that was
very, very nice and I thought
okay, I have to do something like that, so baraba and
tattoo and really  that you come in I
think wow wow wow you have a bit of
an experience as they say
when you go in and then we are
really so now it's not some promo
nonsense that I'm telling you, we
really flew to America to have a
bangbang
look there  like the craziest studio in the world
and in New York and we looked at
all the studios in New York in Las Vegas in LA
to really see okay
if we want to play along
with the craziest studios all over the world I want to
see what they can do, what do you have  In the
end I invested in the studio,
I think around 400 to 450,000, that
's actually still beyond estimate um
and that's a good location in Vienna
or is it a good location in Vienna okay and
what's next in your
portfolio?  I would like to
do a podcast. I would like to
do a podcast.
Actually, what I would like to do at
some point, who will coffee at some point,
I will take my time and then I would
also give it my family name,
so that would be one thing that I would
like to do  but what would happen with your
whole music management thing that
of course it works so we are so
RBK is really together with Ron B Ron B is a
music manager that has been known in Germany for decades yes there is
the music management industry Ronny
is definitely a very very big
figure so if  you would now list
the active greatest people
music management Ronny Bolt definitely one in
2011 so that was very complicated at the time
my best friend in
Berlin Hamudi Royals producer his
brother was the manager of kper kper was
with Beat Gottwald asked Gottwald in exactly
[ __ ] in that  There was someone in the environment
in Sandmann who took me on
board with the publisher, so she made a publishing
deal clear to me at the time. Then Prince
P, Hamudi's brother and
Ronny, founded a management agency,
I signed and
then Ronny left and I  Then I went
out and founded a label with Ron,
who did you have?
Label does its own thing
but how do the administration
behind it and the management so the
management V all when requests
come for cooperation after live
if you want to book them then it
always works exactly exactly for you but that thing
is just what is important to us  It was from the
beginning that we are not
agroberlin, we are not like that now, we are
artists, blah, we are
service providers for the artists and that
is a bit of our style that we
have that makes it a little different than
others, so we write to the
artists  not on the flag s
the other way around so that's an artist
comes and then asks e do you want to
do that and we think yes bomb let's
work together and of course we do
the best that the artist
has perfect accounting and is protected from the outside in
many other things  and yes, you
also say a little bit that I would
n't do that, I would do it and so it
depends on which one so it depends
if you ask me so no matter
which artist I'm of course there
and give my opinion and it was  At the
beginning it was like that too, but then at
some point the artists became so big, so now it's
not because of us and simply because of the
artists themselves because they've simply become big, so at some point
the artists themselves just know what
they're doing at BS, it's a bit of an
exception, I advise B and BS  So he
often advises me because we just
have a story together,
but actually we let the
artist or the artist do what he
thinks and we don't help the artist on
his way the other way around,
okay, let's understand anyway, I
think you have to do all of that  Yes, don't
do it at all because you could
easily get some of the streaming, there must
be millions every year because of
how many streams there are, how big
it is, so if someone knows how Spotify
works, in the best case scenario then it's you and
there will be millions  every year that
means you do the rest just because
you enjoy the bra, you mean, yes, of course, so it does
n't have to be that way, no, because of
life, you mean yes le or
or generally I mean there is
a statement like that from you  that
I don't need any money anyway, it's enough
just with the stream one of the
last few years, which
will probably come in the next few years. I mean,
that's yes, yes, yes, so you do it,
but then again it's a very
philosophical question, so to speak  Of course,
at some point I'll knock vololz and I'm
incredibly grateful that
I. It sounds stupid. Of course
I've got something taken care of somewhere, so I
no longer have to go to work to
survive, yes, but what what is life
worth what you if you if you your
Passion I didn't have fun
so I didn't start music now
because I just hey I
want to become a well-known artist now
and fame and blah blah S is my
passion my my calling
somewhere and everything is part of it so
I always do so I
I wouldn't necessarily be a
stock seller,
so to speak, where all I care about is money and
my goal is not to become Leonardo DiCaprio
in Wolf of Wall Street, but
I actually do what
fulfills me and management is part of that too
For me, such site businesses are
things that fulfill me because I
simply enjoy it and I think
that's basically why every
person somewhere strives for infinity and
self-realization and for me
that's just my kind of
self-realization, doing projects
and
completing them successfully  So
maybe they'll last longer than
I'll live, who knows? What
will definitely have value beyond your lifetime is
the rights to your music, they're
all yours, exactly, yes, but
I'll sell some of it  That means
we're seeing that everywhere right now,
so all the bigger artists from
white to Queen Queen, whoever they are, they're
all being approached,
then some of them buy some kind of
investment fund, the rights because you
can calculate it so well now and it
's worth a huge amount and that's where you are now  It was
also logically mentioned
because the song rights that
you have are already worth a lot,
worth a lot, yes, we're talking about double-digit
million sums, yes, and then you
already know when and who you're selling, no, so
I do, or yes, I ca
n't do it, the podcast  say but
things are going on right now, conversations are
going on right now and somehow now is
just a good time
to do whoever you get the money once
and then but I mean there are
also cases where you get
annoyed afterwards, I think Tay  Swift also
sold the rights once, then Scooter Brown
then there was a lot of trouble and everything,
but the thing is just
simple for me, I'm concerned about something
else, I'm just concerned about that. I
bought a lot of real estate, so
I put everything in the first money
Real estate and in Vienna in
Germany, especially in Berlin in Vienna,
we have now bought an apartment building
and so on, so I'm
well into it and the thing is, I know
that all the things you can get
the money out of  I know
what I mean for decades and the thing is, I
'm 39, I
think I would like to have one now
too, I know in 10
20 years this money from what
I've planted will somehow come
out and that's why I'm now finding a
real one  It's time for me to get some money
with which I can then maybe go back to
work and do something that
I enjoy right now, so while drinking
beer, that's what it means
or no, so we have a rental property
is 30 30 houses
like 25 somehow like that apartment in the house yes
apartment in the house and dreag shot exactly
and then just otherwise real
estate where so a few ma I rbnb
in Vienna I have a few where I do rbnb
then  I have a lot of apartments
where family members live so my
mother a cousin my sister this so
something like that yes so you
provide for a little bit yes provide for the
family so a little bit exactly okay but you
know the family the real estate game
pretty well pretty well not
but  For me it's a very simple
game, sorry to everyone in the
real estate game, I don't want to say so
of course there are real estate billionaires
are a lot tougher and know
all the tricks but in the end
it's all about you buying the property
and in the best case scenario it will come later
be worth more and that's why it's
not that complicated okay so but so location location location
I've heard yes of course of course so of
course that's what it's all
about so if you buy now in
a location where you
can build infinitely much is just
logical  That then maybe there won't be
as much of an increase in value as
something where it's so scarce that there ca
n't be anything left, that's clear, so you
know what I mean, but I've already had people
here explain it to me
what there is
huge lever behind in the in the game
so if you do it right
100% but the thing is that
the principle itself in real estate
is, in my opinion, relatively easy
to understand for an idiot like
me, but that's just logical, you
buy real estate and  Of course, if
the situation is good and if you can't
build endless things around it,
the situation will remain relatively stable
unless there's a war or
I don't know what's coming, so
things like
Bitcoins and nfts where there are simply things that are actually relatively logical
You can't explain it
to me, it's rather complicated. Someone
wrote it down for me to talk to you in
Falco, where they speak Austria. Does
that somehow
mean something to you,
or is that our greatest
legend, so to speak?  you
greener or is greener Hamburger no
no no he is he is bchummer but
Hamburg Lindberg Udo exactly that is
our F only that ours is death and
ours was a little more controversial
than yours but otherwise B is a fan yes yes
who isn't so I think  I know a little
Viennese who doesn't say yes, Falk is
what our legend is, okay, okay,
I mean, but
I think it's amazing that
genres are now crossing over because they're committed to
things, so h just kind of
nirevana, you don't have any inhibitions like that either
In general, to have conversations that
now go beyond what we have as an
image of you from a distance, so
of course I used to have it when
I was younger and started
with rap and was at home in Bosnia with my friend emires
and then we
heard Jawne and he said do
n't tell anyone that we're
doing that, so in the past as a teenager, something like that,
you might have been ashamed,
but not now, what do you have the
next few years, so if the music
is less now, like I said, a
podcast  so I'm talking about it separately W I'm getting really
curious what I've been
thinking about
is actually studying either psychology
or philosophy again
so I'm starting to study it
I'm incredibly interested in Z topic
and yes otherwise just
wait a little bit hold on twice
and then  take a breath then
attack again so then make music again
yes yes of course so of course it's
a break for me right now
but take a bit of a breath to
find yourself again okay what do you want to
represent now what will the new version of
Raf kamora be when I come back
but it  I'll definitely
come back at some point, I mean, I
always have the feeling that you have to
play hard on such a social platform. I
've just looked at on insta, for example,
you only do very little,
it's not really important now,
so  Let's say I don't do it
so little that then
too little but I'm doing it now I
'm not an influencer what you I've
looked at I think somehow 130 posts
or something like that or if at all on
my feed me so yes yes I always delete that
Here I am again, like with us, so
if I were to put everything online that
I have, I have
no idea here 1000 2000 posts but I keep posting,
I liked it, it was always 187
always
187 but the cool thing about it follows no yes
me  You also follow, I don't follow either, I
just upload my tattoo
as a statement or or so I
copied it from my receipts at the beginning. I
thought the same thing because
otherwise everyone asks why don't you follow
me why do you follow him why
follow  you blah blah and it gets
confusing and then your
following thing is no longer a promo tool at all, so you
know what I mean when you follow like 50,000
people and then you have to
unfollow someone who is [ __ ] and blah blah
and that just causes too many problems
right from the start  I didn't follow anyone,
but I find
extremely clear
communication when it comes to this platform. I copied something from you,
namely we
were in contact for the first time years ago because of B, we
texted WhatsApp and there
you had voice messages
under 45 please  Seconds I
stole that straight away, that's true, but if you don't have
any more, I don't have any more then I
definitely have to write it down again
because that's why I think it's almost
rude if someone sends me the language
that's over two minutes is W
over a minute  It's still okay, but
actually the length is
rude for me. I think to myself, make it
shorter, you can hpentig so that
in 30 seconds, you
actually know all of this digital platform,
so you know exactly how it
works, yes, I'm not
75  trot feeling you and it's
so important for your life so I mean
if you think about it, take a little break
and then you want to
attack again how do you communicate that you're
attacking then actually in the end via
Instagram via Instagram but that's what
I always really like  I do and what I've
always done in my
career are kickoffs, so we've
always had very strong kickoffs
like the kickoff I had
for my album zit, that was back then where
I said okay, now I'll stop
because that's really it  The plan was
I projected the release edition of this album on the sofieil in the
city center in Vienna
and I told him beforehand to
basically the whole city, hey then
and then at such and such an hour, so
I haven't said where it will be yet
but  I said I'm going to
announce in Vienna when my last album is
coming out. Vienna knows first and then
from day to day I have a
raven like that, so to speak,
my logo is like a raven over a
zone in Vienna  Let it fly digitally
so that they can see it, okay, that's
about where it will be and until the evening,
I think it was around 9 p.m.,
the frame got smaller and smaller and then
people knew, ah, okay, it's
in the Sofie part and I guess there were people
like that  10,000 people in the city center
filmed when the album was released and
Bones drove a boat over the
donor and
shot T-shirts into the crowd and
it was really unbelievable that you were
really staging it like that and Mark,
so it was for me  is marketing art
and I enjoy it, it's really
e.g. now with shiagu we
did a concert at a gas station in
Vienna and a video shoot and
told people to sign up if
you want to be part of the video shoot and
so and there  There were about 2,000 people who
came and that was the video
and it was really cool and ESWT
on the one hand was really cool we played through tiktok
earlier because now, in
contrast to before, the
anties phase of a song is much
longer and much more important that means we
had a very nice teaser phase because
people all filmed the concert
then there were excerpts from the song
blah blah blah
m yes but marketing is fun what was
the stickering I've now noticed
that was crazy now say a one
or tell me why
Raven because you just my your logo why
the raven um so the raven firstly so
there is the very romantic filmic
story is that I lived as a child
so I lived in the schat schatl
is that in the Geneva seeh there because
my grandpa worked in
vineyards
It's also embellished but apparently
my first words were the sounds of
ravens and I watched the ravens a
bit like Batman and
yes and that's why the raven, it was
always an animal that somehow
fascinated me and later I
wrote a song in 2010 I think
was that and the hi black raven and it
was about me
saying in the song itself, I'm okay
with the music, it's not working and [ __ ]
and thing and then a black
raven comes along, a bit like hot bottom, knocks on the
f and says e if you can do it
want to do the music then come on let's do it
together
and then this and that will happen you
will be successful and in the song I
just think about it again and see wow
the dark side of success blah blah
and I decide against it like that and
that was the song  black raven back then
and that's why raven that's why
my book is packed where it's just about
a little bit about
a lot of people metaphorically so I
saw things on tiktok like Satanist W
sold his soul to the devil for €35, that
's of course nonsense  I
even go to church so nonsense but I
really think I actually go to
church as a Protestant or
Catholic Roman Catholic but one
thing that is important to me I
don't mix religion into anything
but I personally go to
church
and how  said on tiktok there were a
lot of videos where people didn't
understand that it
's a bit of a metaphor
with the
raven but it's like how should you say
the spirit animal the symbol everyone
needs everything so its symbols for me  was
the raven I mean that means you did the
campaign in Vienna tell me
two more things from the
marketing mistakes from rfcamor so you
the sticker at the very beginning now that you
can do such things in Vienna there are
such installations  on or something like that,
throwing projections on buildings and
then
announcing music, what else is going on,
so as I said,
I also found the last action with Chiago to be crazy
at the gas station, that was
intense back then with B for the 187
sler, there was also one of mine  In my opinion, according to the
supermketing strategy that we thought about at the time,
the
sampler came out without pre-ordering,
which means people could because I
was thinking about the iPhone when the
new iPhone comes out, so people basically camp in
front of the store so that they all
have this iPhone and  For us, the thing was
okay when the sampler comes,
people should actually leave the store to
make everything a bit more physical again. We thought it would be
cool if people actually stood in front of the store
like they did when a CD came out
People were all waiting for the CD
and to push that a bit,
let's not pre-order
but get the CD directly in the store and
then it was on a Tuesday on
July 18th 17th and of course ah okay okay
okay and then that was there  That was
crazy back then, then people were
really waiting in front of the store and that
was the idea of ​​like Sneaker
Drop in the end and that's what
nobody did in music, that
worked out great and the album is
also on one  gone then it was
despite no pre-order without nothing
you also did things where you always
put things in the record so
the big issue is
that in the end people don't even buy
the record anymore but it will
anyway  counted fan boxes and so on,
then you put any discarded
things into the fan box and things like that.
Yes, I have to honestly say that with
these fan boxes and so on,
if it makes sense then that's great,
but if it doesn't make sense it'll slowly
become a reality at some point  ridiculous and that's
why I always tried to put
things in the fan boxes,
like books, because
I think books really have
a value, that's one thing that
's not too expensive, so when it comes to
production, that means you can get it
somehow  In terms of price, make sure
that the Fan Fanbox isn't too expensive,
but recently I've been adding books a lot,
I mean, you've also
written two books, yes, but also
bestsellers, um, but I still found
the circulation numbers that I could see
weren't that big, so now  for
for the book I think somehow I do
n't know what crazy numbers are
for books I think so if you
're a big author in Germany in the German-speaking area you do
n't sell 100,000 real books per year, so some of them
are not biographies but somehow fictional ones  I don't think
it was 50,000, we did it,
I think it's okay, but that
was just important to you, it's not a business, it was
important to you, yes, yes, it was important and that
was also that was all part of the
comeback, so I actually got in
On the last page of this gripping book I
basically wrote a saying
that
was if the burden is too big for your love, do
n't get rid of the love and
get rid of the burden and then you
actually understood after that that I
would make music again and I
I thought to myself at the time that
the effect would be more extreme so I thought to
myself that the fans will all check it out
and everyone will talk about it but
no one talked about it so it did
n't work but it was actually
my plan I thought okay  I I uh
write this now and everyone will
talk about it e he wants to come back he
wants to come back he wants to come back
we I also planned it the same way that
the book came out I think on June 4th
and then my album came out on July 16th which
by the way  That was a
good marketing move,
we came without notice
and there
's also a funny story, so
we had made a logo and it was
agreed upon. Everyone posts it from
our people somehow the next day
at 4 p.m. or 6
p.m  the next day I look on
Instagram and see B just
posted at 12 p.m. and then I was
really angry and called us and said
you ruined my whole marketing plan,
you have a problem why 12 p.m. we
said all 6 p.m  or 4
p.m. and we then have an effect if you all
post at the same time ah yes sorry then we got
together but we somehow I think
I was sorry for my marketing gag,
he
wrote to everyone he knows and asked if they would
please do the same  can and then people
posted this logo that I didn't even
know in the slightest, any
players from Spain know the logo is
all because it's easy. It's also
different when you ask for someone
than when you ask for yourself and
he told me back then  helped incredibly
and then made the campaign 1000 times
bigger. Somehow
everyone felt this sign,
I think even flir posted it even though flir
was enemies with us or something and it was
really awesome and then the album came out
at midnight BAM  It just came out
when you now, so to speak, for brand work,
there is also the fact that you
do brand collaborations, speaking of
Austria, right there you can hear
which
drink is that so that you are
also involved in some way, I mean,
you are now doing Puma right now
They do a lot of things with Rocky anyway, I've
now seen Puma as well, so they
seem to have a bit of an interest in
the box on the music channel,
so they get involved or is it
somehow so active or say they're
just here with your clothes like it's
going on  something like that so yes I
definitely have the right to decide with
whom so don't say now you're kick no so of
course you decide with me
and Puma so I'll say I'm
relatively pain-free because for me it's
sorry I hope I'll do it  So
now it's not in
breach of contract I think adidas is good I
think Nike is good I think Puma is good I think
all the sports brands there aren't now where
I say it's [ __ ] it's good
and so far I think they're all good so
they all have cool shoes  thing
and for me it's more about who
is the better partner as you know and
who with whom I have the prospect of
doing any projects who is
also behind it who wants to do that
that was Puma projects then means own
shoe or own line can do everything  It
can be anything, it can also be then, hey, you
feel like going to China after I freestyle
and building a music studio there
and then making a Chinese rap album.
I won't do it, but we're
like, somehow the more
open and the better the
reference person is  You just have the
brand the better and at Puma
the people were cool somehow but fashion
is a bit your thing anyway that's
why I thought that I do
n't want fashion so I'll do merch
better good merchandise fashion is
like if now there's almost no fashion  Idea
opera singer comes and once wrote a part
says I'm a
rapper now so fashion is such a badass
you have to be like that butell is now
suddenly creative director at lwm
as or something like that you look at something like that do you
follow SAS I heard  But
the thing is, Farell is perhaps
a lot more fashionable than me, so
I have my own style that I
like to wear, and I would now also
say that I can do it, so I can
also dress so that you don't feel ashamed of it, so
to speak, but I  I'm far away
from FASHION, you look at what
the Americans can do and Adidas
think you can say whatever you want,
but the guy really invented a great
shoe, yes, it's awesome, but
you won't believe that,
no  So I think I
just don't see myself as a crazy
fashioner now, so I'd like to do it that way,
but everyone to their strengths, there are
so many brands or so many
that tell you to try it out, I'm
sure you'll hear wel say okay  Sure,
if you have an idea for a cool shoe that
I like, then
solve it like I said, just like the example
that I already had with these with
these different shots you have, so
if I make another shoe now then
I don't know  Do I still
make the coffee? So you just have to
think about what you're doing and what's
most beneficial and of course it makes sense
and if there's a blatant possibility,
I'm open to anything, anything but
no pizza, no, no, that's already
done  No, as a pizza it would also be for
me as an Italian, it would be like I have
no idea, like I can't even
make it. Selling frozen pizza, that would be a
shame, okay, that's true, that's a
huge shame, but you can tell a great
story, I'm an Italian,
I would like it to be delicious to every Italian  betrayed so
that's even my mother who
actually doesn't give a [ __ ],
she also says we don't eat
frozen pizza we are somewhere
part of our culture who doesn't
eat pizzaiz with ketchup so pizza does
n't need to report it doesn't do anything
else  you would like
to make coffee, as I said, I think it's
really interesting to make coffee in a
podcast, but what's supposed to go well
I don't know who told me that,
whether it was on the record off the record,
someone sells
a lot of tobacco, I think, ah yes  yes, that's what it
does. 187 sells a lot of tobacco
online
It's so strong, so you wo
n't really know what I mean, it depends on the
artist's hype because, for example, massively,
he makes a lot of money with tobacco,
but now it's not that strong in terms of streaming
how strong you
are as an artist so
yes that means you need the
infrastructure it has to be so good that
it's up you need the partner so it's
the same as
with any time business if you
have a really strong partner who
invests in it that's really good
power then you are also strong and that
's especially true with tobacco. You
need really good people, people who
are legit, who have a name in the
tobacco industry, who have the dealers who
buy from them and then there
have to be huge fairy tales  It's
unbelievable, they make an unbelievable amount of
money, you can't imagine
exactly. I was once told IR
and then I also thought, old
Swede, that
you can't do that or I wouldn't have
come up with it. I thought, okay, music and
then clothes and then I think  you do things like that
and suddenly tobacco is
huge, so I don't have any numbers
and no names except for
Bones, but when they were listed
for 187 tobacco and the partners
said so and so much money would be
there  jumping out, my manager and
I looked at each other and said yes, okay,
never thought it was good, but let's try it,
maybe so worse than that it doesn't
work, you can't say, but that's
actually how it was, but for you
it's not an issue Shisha tobacco, yes, for example, it
's just me  So far away from that, that's the
thing, so I wouldn't have a problem
selling something that I don't do
every day, but
I'm a bit missing the connection if
someone is interested and has suggestions about what
else they can do with you
then I'll send it on
so write to me or
the management will write and let's see what happens.
I'm always happy when the podcast
here produces productive things. In
any case, as I said, that's what
I'm really keen on in the future
39 and I'm
turning 40, that means to
me what I
would really like to do would be things like you
can actively improve your own life and others too, but
without that all that greasy
hey, I have the toe rules for your
wealth template for  So that's definitely
not the case, but somehow a
kind of I don't know, both
psychologically and physically,
just work on yourself, but do
you feel the need to really
pass it on, so completely extreme than
really, that's really a thing that
I like to do  I would
also like a little bit of one because if we're
talking about fitness
and things like that, I think,
for example, that the fitness trainers
M are the ones that breed
things like sleep problems, for example, you know
when you're told so often hey  if
your sleep isn't good then you have
BL you know they make people so
stressed about eating so much stressed about
sleeping so much stressed about training
that in the end you're so stressed that
you're actually rather
counterproductive we know and because
the pressure is so great the pressure is so great oh
[ __ ] I haven't slept for my 8
hours now I didn't
fall asleep after 15 minutes I woke
up three times [ __ ] my life
is [ __ ] up but you know what I mean
and that's just how I believe it  There are
just other approaches and my book that
I wrote dark Z and that's
actually one thing that I
like to talk about and would also like to talk about
is because
I wrote down a little bit
about what my learnings
were about what
m yes what uh uh with what  I went out and
for me these are actually the
treasures that I got
after 15 or 20 years in the dark music industry
because so many things
happen to me. Order Amazon no you ca
n't no you can't so darken
I really have the book  just
as included in the box as I
thought, so if someone listens here
and wants to get that Kri Kri doesn't mean
that hot, they'll have to listen to the Dark Podcast next,
actually because for me
it's just um the book
is how should I describe it?
if you are a car lover and you know
okay this car drives so fast and
this car drives so fast and so
on and you write about it but you
are not a mechanic and it was the same
for me so dark I wrote
are my experiences and I have with
um  Of course, I sat down with people
from the field and talked about things
and so on and
packed all that in, but I'm not a
psychologist, I have
n't studied any of it, I actually have
no idea about it, which means that my
hypotheses that I wrote in there
I have to bring this onto the market and
then you have Rafel ragucci dark and
next to it you have Adler, so by thing I mean I
can't
play in the same field yet, so
it was important to me that I give it to my fans
first so that they read it  I want them to
see what my approach
is, but if I really want to
deepen it then I have to
deal with it more and
then I have to talk about it because
it's difficult, everything you write is
just black and white, you have
it now  I said that, I mean,
you can, you really have to
concentrate on making sure that what you say
is really comprehensible
and I probably
said legit ten times today, but yes,
it's legit, but I'm still a little
worried about some of the listeners here  Listeners
everyone wants to have that you want to
give it on eBay or maybe I know I did
n't google it so who has it I
guess it's now worth a lot on Ebay
book I think it's really
nice so the book is
nice worth reading I think it's worth reading because
First of all, of course, it's
about the dark rules that I have
set up for myself, such as no idea
ikig that so so so a term that comes from Japan
for the joy of life and
so on so ik is
inviolable or things like avoid
avoid BL just things but then
Rules that I relate to
things that really happened to me in
my career such as I have
no
idea, I wouldn't have
asked about the feature back then because I was
ashamed to ask him and
contact with Bonses never
came about  you know and that was just because
I avoided to
avoid so because I just thought
no I can't ask never Bo makes
me uncomfortable what if he says no
you know I gave a [ __ ] and
thought no I'll do it like that and that
For me it was just a learning experience, to put it bluntly,
for many
other areas of life and
avoidance can also be the same
if you're complex because you somehow do
n't think you're pretty and then you
never go swimming because you think I
always look like [ __ ] and blah blah that  Then
you don't grow with it. You then
try to avoid it,
maybe just go with your towel and throw it at
some point. You can
imagine it extremely well, so say what
you've learned on your way,
what works for you somehow, plus the
rules then you have it  You stole from the
Japanese theory
and everything that worked for you came
from psychotherapy
and things like that, so
I can
imagine the rules of life quite well, I
mean, and probably somehow
it would  Helping people, I mean, you
're now very rested and
responsible. That's
a topic that you're not a big fan
of, but maybe I can
ask because with your fame and your
reach, you have
responsibility. That's the topic, so the question
is  difficult because, of course, on
the one hand, from a moral point of view, you
always have responsibility somewhere, yes,
but the art you make is
just like when someone makes action films, to put it bluntly,
on the one hand,
of course, like every person in the
world, they have some kind of responsibility,
but if you now  So you do Rambo, you
write the film, then it becomes Rambo. I
've never seen Rambo, but I
assume Rambo also kills someone in the
film. I know what I mean and of course it's
not good to show someone who
kills someone and is also strong and you
want to be  like Rambo you know but it's
just an action film and the music
we make is action music somewhere
if you want, you know, we talk about
partying, talking about sex, we're talking about
shooting, we're talking about drugs, we're talking
about everything that's action in life and
But that's the film we're going to see
if we stopped
talking about all this now then we would
n't have one at all, our music would be completely
different, one day there'll be RAF
the family man and that's a big question,
so that's actually for me
too  a very big topic m
I'm just very, very happy that I do
n't have a family yet, so I'm
super happy because somehow God or
fate
gave me space for my
self-realization because I always
find it difficult when, on the one hand, you have
your self-realization but
on the other hand you have the realization of
your family and I personally am
glad that I was able to really put my focus
on that and that as long as
my focus is so passionate about it there
is nothing wrong if I
want to reorient myself one day then
maybe so  none yet so there
are no plans there are no no so
I'm neither in a relationship nor in
so I'm de your art is
somehow absorbed that's the
thing so my my
ex-girlfriend really really loves me a
lot  worth it was um said back then um
first and foremost you are married to your
music and to your art then
nothing comes for a long time and then comes
your family and me but first and
foremost you have so much to do with what
you want to do and me  I have to
honestly say that it would be like cheating
if you're actually so passionate about one
thing, your music, your
art, your projects,
and the other person is actually just
running on the side, you know, and that's just
the thing and for me
Actually, I love what I
do, I'm happy every day and
grateful every day to be able to do what
I do. When you listen to it, it seems
totally reflected and thought through and
so someone has dealt with themselves
and their
possibilities and doesn't come  People from
politics and stuff like that and want to say something about
you, man, call for the vote
or do you do that or
business also a little business
guide that we always say handicrafts
of religion politics blad is a
difficult topic and that's
why  I don't discuss politics,
religion or too blatant sexuality
and so on because these are simply
things that are to a certain extent
everyone's private decision about what they do, so
of course I'm much more left-wing, so yes,
but I wouldn't now, hey, that's
the party  and the strong one, we
shot a clip back then when I
was there, it was for the SPÖ, they
financed it because they always
financed music, um but if I
went into politics now, Rafael
sitting in front of you says no, I have no
idea  15 years ago, maybe I think
that's my thing, I'm in politics,
but currently no crazy, so
yes, I am, I always found it
exciting how you appeared, what
you built there, but I also think it's
incredibly reflective and and so
you're not  disappointed with our podcast
not at all not at
all so mee Verge has been
after you for years it's kind of hard to
get hold of you no but I mean we've
often had contact like that here or
there and I've always been that way and I was
jealous of that too  the forbs colleagues
because they had D on the cover [ __ ] hey
why is he doing that now there
could have been a podcast yes but one does
n't exclude the other maybe
one even makes the other better so well
anyway yes
respect and thank you very much for that  you
came and thank you, I'm
sure we'll see each other here and there
again, I hope at the next festival.
You were sick, that was it
too  I was
actually very annoyed
because I also thought in advance that
it was so crazy, I've never done it like
that before and then I did it exactly for the forbs,
in the same way as
it was with you,
but that  was a very small frame and that's
why next year that's
definitely a thing where I where I
say that's a bit of a jump in the deep end
for me when will
the big rfcamur Netflix Lok
Netflix loku actually come? Yes, I hate
being filmed  is the problem I like must there
must be a lot of stuff from you
someone GEF you every year
so much must have been created and I do
n't want people to see that so I'm I'm
not a fan of the camera that's the
thing that's for  me the problem that's
why I love podcast radio
interviews everything but it's called me apachche there was
already a big documentary that I
like cameras more than me
so I don't know maybe so if
I somehow find a way but it will
take more effort  If I
wanted it to be
more cinematic, more than anything, I think it goes a
long way when as an artist you represent a certain
thing, but with Bushido it
irritated me a bit in the documentary because for me Bushido was
always Bushido  It
bothered me that when I was watching the documentary, I was
basically shown hanging around in his T-shirt.
I thought, okay,
on the one hand, authentic and blah, blah, but
on the other hand, as an artist, you want
something, how should you
put it, so then,
um, yours  Carry on a fictional character somehow, you
know what I mean and there
's maybe that's
just a thing for me that I don't want
if people want to see you now except
maybe at OMR next year when
say what is March in March in March is
my tour  I'm
really looking forward to it, it's actually the Phantom Tour
because for me it's
kind of the final tour
of a phase, so for me it's
rafcamor 2016 to
2023 and then Camora becomes
the Phantom after that, I said in a
song and that's why the phantom tour  in
Hamburg Austria Switzerland
Austria and Switzerland exactly tip top
all clear great now team what my
colleagues say this podcast is
produced by
podstars at
OMR